Okay, so I've talked before about how the
program is constantly iterating and changing
and I want to be improving the show and making
the program reflective, not only of what I
think are important political issues, but
making the format reflective of what people
in the audience enjoy.
And so we had some questions that I asked
last week about interview duration and story
duration, number of stories per day, live
calls versus voicemails.
And I have the results now hundreds and hundreds
of people emailed me.
Some of the trends are very clear and on some
questions the audience seems kind of undecided
or at least in different, we could say.
So here are the results from what we asked
you about last week.
First of all, should interviews be reduced
in number and extended in length?
This was the most overwhelming result.
73% of the audience wants fewer interviews
that are longer.
Um, 27% does not want that change.
So that's a really significant, uh, a result.
Should voicemails be replaced with live calls?
The answer is no.
80% of the audience says no, no, no.
Keep the voicemails and don't replace them
with live calls.
Should we cover more stories per show?
It's almost a 50, 50 split, 45%.
Say cover more stories per show, 55% say don't.
And then should each story be longer in duration?
Almost two thirds of you said yes.
Extend the stories a bit, a little more than
one third said no.
So, uh, some pretty significant numbers there
at least as far as people are going in the
direction of preferring longer form content.
That seems to be the trend.
Wanting interviews to be longer and fewer
in number wanting stories to be longer and
roughly the same in number based on these
results.
Some other common requests or ideas that came
from people who uh, got in touch.
One idea was canceled the Friday classic interviews,
uh, saying, listen, David, those interviews
are available on the youtube channel.
It can sometimes be interesting to sort of
like revive, revive an old interview, but
we can find them.
You could probably do something better with
that time.
Also a lot of requests for more of our deep
dive long forms segments, which is something
we're considering.
And then also lots of ideas about what I should
be doing when we launch on twitch.
The David Pakman show is in very advanced
discussions with twitch and their partner
team.
Uh, and some of the ideas that people came
up with used twitch just to take audience
calls and questions, pull some of that stuff
off of the youtube channel, do it on twitch,
uh, play chess, uh, presumably against members
of the audience or not.
But, uh, do some, uh, playing of chess, even
though I'm not that good.
I do play chess.
I enjoy it.
I could do that on twitch show prep behind
the scenes.
In other words, pull up a browser and actually
show how I go through the research and preparation
process for the show.
Uh, show how I create my notes, show how I,
um, gather clips and quotes and charts that
I will be using on the program like the next
day, for example.
Interesting idea.
Uh, pull up the old David Pakman show videos
and comment on them.
In other words, pull up like a video from
six years ago, play it, and then explore whether
my view has changed or it's the same or whatever.
A play Mario brothers or Tetris, I guess people
mentioning those games because I play very
few video games, but those are two that historically
I used to play, uh, take political tests like
the political compass, compass test and others
as part of these twitch streams or play my
drums, which I would love to do, but I don't
really have them properly miked right now.
And just like ambient drum sound onto a regular
microphone is not the best thing.
So those are all really great ideas.
So here's what we're doing in the immediate
number one, we are going to start making some
tweaks with regard to interview and story
length that are reflective of what people
want.
But for everybody who says everything's fine,
no need to worry, there's not going to be
any massive changes or upending of the program.
It's just really little quick tweaks to keep
iterating and make the show the best possible
show for today's audience demands and interests
which have changed over time.
Understandably.
Number two, there is something I want to let
you know about going on with twitch.
Uh, w if you have an Amazon prime membership,
and I know many people in the audience, do
you get a free monthly twitch membership,
one that you can use to sign up for the channel
of your choice.
Normally that costs $5 a month, but if you
have an Amazon prime membership, you are gifted
a credit for one twitch membership per month.
You can use that free twitch membership eventually
to support the David Pakman show on twitch.
Okay.
So if you have an Amazon prime membership
and you aren't currently on twitch, what I
would ask you to do to prepare for the launch
of the show on twitch is make an account on
twitch, connect your Amazon prime account
to your twitch account.
You can Google how to do that.
And then when the time comes, I will let you
know when you can assign your free, your Freebie
a twitch membership.
Uh, thanks to being an Amazon prime member
to the David Pakman show.
Okay.
So you can do that in advance just to prepare.
Uh, and I will let you know when we were ready
to launch on that front.